well we're so pleased to have with us
tonight the legal scholar and UC
professor Daniel Farber who's here to
discuss his latest book retained by the
people the silent 9th amendment and the
constitutional rights Americans don't
know they have in this book
professor Farber explores the history
and meaning and intent of the
little-known ninth amendment and without
further ado here's professor farmer
[Applause]
thanks it's a great pleasure to be here
tonight
the big question whenever I walk in a
bookstore is how much will I spend
before I get out again and so we'll see
how that goes tonight the subject of
this book is seemingly esoteric question
of legal theory does the Constitution
only protect the specific rights that
are listed like freedom of speech or
freedom of religion or does it also
protect other rights now one of the
reasons this is so important is that
there really aren't that many rights
listed there there are eight amendments
to the Constitution that lists specific
rights almost all of those rights relate
to the criminal justice process search
warrants right to counsel and so forth
those are very important but outside of
criminal justice there's much more
selective coverage and religion and
speech are probably the most important
of the rights that are dealt with there
are all kinds of other things that are
really important that are not
specifically discussed and I thought
might be helpful for me to give some
examples of real cases in which the
issue of enumerate unenumerated rights
would make a difference that as cases
where it seems like the government's
doing something really wrong but the
Constitution doesn't say anything
specifically against it the first and
earliest of these cases involved a woman
named Carrie buck who lived in Virginia
early in the 20s
century and carry buck was confined to a
mental institution on the basis of
mental retardation and under a Virginia
law that was in existence at that time
she was sterilized because the law
provided for sterilization of people who
were quote defective the question before
the Supreme Court was whether this
violated her constitutional rights and
in a famous opinion the Supreme Court
said no it didn't violate any
constitutional right as the Justice
Holmes who wrote the opinion said three
generations of imbeciles are enough as
it turned out she was not in fact
mentally disabled she had been put in
the institution by her foster parents
because she became pregnant and was an
embarrassment to the family but that was
only discovered much later through
research by Stephen Jay Gould and others
who looked into the case now there's
nothing in the Constitution that says
you have a right not to be sterilized or
a right not to be on the other hand
required to have children the
Constitution is just silent about that
in terms of explicit language a second
case is much more recent from the 1970s
involved a woman named Moore and she was
sentenced to jail for five days what was
her crime this was by city in Ohio what
was her crime you might wonder well her
crime was that she invited one of her
young grandchildren who didn't have
parental care to come live with her and
that was a violation of the local zoning
ordinance it was a violation because she
already had two grandchildren child
living with with her and under the
ordinance that was the max she could not
have a second grandchild without
violating the terms of the ordinance so
she was sentenced to jail for
the crime of taking in a grandchild the
Supreme Court did rule in her favor in a
5-4 decision with a great deal of
anxiety and hair-pulling on the part of
the majority and a vigorous dissent so
by a vote to actually four to one to
four she was allowed to go free
rather than serve for jail time another
recent case involved a boy named Joshua
to Shanee Joshua was a little boy who
was living with his father his parents
had divorced and Joshua kept showing up
in the emergency room with broken bones
bruises other injuries that medical
people called Protective Services
I believe school people also intervened
the neighbors called the police
a social worker dutifully kept a file of
all these complaints but did nothing
ultimately Joshua's father beat him into
a coma which at least as of the time of
the Supreme Court decision he had never
recovered from the Supreme Court said
that his rights weren't violated because
there's no constitutional rights to be
protected by the government doesn't say
anywhere in the Constitution that the
government has to lift a single finger
to protect you from violence so these
are all cases which at least raise the
question of whether the Constitution
goes beyond this explicit list and
whether it protects additional rights
the cases in some sense should be pretty
easy it seems to me that almost
everybody regardless of their politics
should be able to agree that something
was wrong in these cases that we
Americans don't expect our government to
act like that that people have a right
to better treatment the reason that
these cases were so difficult in the
Supreme Court primarily was a resistance
to the whole idea of unenumerated rights
and a fear that if we recognize some an
unenumerated rights who knows what the
judges might do next so many leading
jurists i think justice scalia most
notably today
the Supreme Court Judge Bork a few years
ago a number of my colleagues and the
legal Academy including at least one
who's just down the hall from me all
believe that the idea of unenumerated
rights is illegitimate
now paradoxically most of these people
claim to believe in the original intent
of the framers and they claim to believe
that judges should just follow the text
of the Constitution so to some extent
these people have claimed the high
ground they're not making political
decisions they're simply following what
the history and language of the
Constitution tell them to do let the
chips fall where they may
it's their opponents the ones who want
to set grandma more free or to protect
Joshua to Shanee it's their opponents
who were the ones who were being
political and just reading their
personal values into the Constitution
and so one of the main things I wanted
to do in this book was to try to rebut
that view of what the text of the
Constitution says and what the history
says I've been working on one of the
things people ask is how long did it
take to write this book and that's very
difficult for me to answer in this case
the actual writing didn't necessarily
take that long but in some sense I
started writing at 30 years ago when I
first went into teaching because at that
time I started doing historical research
in constitutional history and in many
ways this book is a natural outgrowth of
the work that I started back then and
frankly I think the conclusion is that
the framers of the original Constitution
the Bill of Rights and the 14th
amendment just didn't share this modern
Scalia typed view of the world
now I'm always a little suspicious when
people come in and claim to have
discovered some secret
that's overwhelmingly clear from history
only nobody but them ever saw it before
right so if it's that clear why didn't
anyone see it that's not true in this
case in fact my view of the history I
think is pretty close to being Orthodox
among constitutional historians it's up
the people outside of that little
specialty don't necessarily know about
and of course there's always
disagreement in academic circles but I
if anything this is what the majority
view in the area is so I lose points for
originality but on the other hand you
know that there might create a little
more comfort and in accepting this view
of the history what what did the framers
think about this whole issue of
unenumerated rights the easiest thing
for a lawyer to do in going back to look
at history is to take a specific issue
like take the phrase unenumerated rights
and do a computer search and find every
time somebody use that phrase and then
show how their view exactly fit with
your thesis that's often called law
office history because it's the way
lawyers write briefs but that doesn't
really get you very far because all
you're getting are these little
fragments they're out of context and
they're lacking an understanding of the
intellectual framework that people had
at the time so what I've tried to do
over the years and what I try to do in
the book in a kind of abbreviated way is
to give some sense of the intellectual
framework that I think that the key
constitutional decision-makers shared
from say the time of the American
Revolution up to reconstruction after
the Civil War and that was also the time
period during which the main portions of
the Constitution and the Bill of Rights
and the later 14th amendment were
created and what was this point of view
well under this point of view people
don't get rights rights don't exist
because somebody graciously lists them
in a document and gives them the rights
the Declaration of Independence speaks
of unalienable rights with which people
are endowed by their creator and that is
really in a nutshell much of the early
view of Rights the framing generation in
particular thought that law was not
limited to specific statutes or even
court cases they saw all of the statutes
in court case
and constitutional provisions as being
locked into a kind of matrix with
background principles of law that were
universally understood and so it's
really kind of surprising when you read
some of the speeches or the writings of
these people to see them citing European
legal philosophers and international law
experts as explaining the nature of
government in terms of what our
Constitution might mean or in terms of
explaining these basic rights they
really just did not have that sense that
if it's not written down it's not a
right they thought it was a right first
and then you wrote it down afterwards
now this became important in the debates
over the Bill of Rights we naturally
think of Constitution as having a bill
of rights what you know that's in some
sense maybe what we think is the main
purpose of a constitution is to protect
individual rights but as originally
proposed and ratified the Constitution
did not contain a bill of rights the
issue of a bill of rights came up very
late in the Constitutional Convention
and they were almost at the end they
were anxious to go home and they brushed
it aside during the campaign to get
approval for the Constitution one of the
major issues was lack of a Bill of
Rights now personally I think they just
left out the Bill of Rights because they
were tired and hot at the end of a long
summer without air-conditioning in
Philadelphia but they couldn't very well
say that and so what the supporters of
the Constitution did was come up with a
bunch of reasons why having a Bill of
Rights was really a bad idea and
therefore it was very clever of them not
to include one and why was this a bad
idea well they had a number of theories
about what was wrong with the Bill of
Rights for one thing the federal
government just wouldn't be strong
enough to violate anyone's rights you
know make your own judgement about that
but another theory was if we list some
rights the list will
[Music]
wait for the train and now okay back to
my train of thought so if they make a
list it'll be incomplete you can't list
all the rights that people have and if
you if the list is incomplete people
will assume that the rights that were
left off the list were meant to be
denied that that that only the rights on
the list would be observed and that the
other rights were in some sense being
superseded or put aside and therefore
since you can't do a complete list and
since a partial list will be dangerous
better not to have a list at all and
just leave all the rights as
unenumerated in the first place
well those arguments had some success
but ultimately they really didn't fly
politically and as part of the condition
for ratifying the Constitution the
supporters of the Constitution agreed to
add a bill of rights and James Madison
was the one who took the lead in this
effort to add the Bill of Rights and he
had spent a lot of time thinking about
Bills of Rights and what they were good
for and what they weren't good for and
one of the arguments that he'd been very
attracted to was this idea that the list
would be incomplete and that would be
bad so as he explained when he
introduced the Bill of Rights he added a
provision to deal with that argument and
that provision was the ninth amendment
the ninth amendment says I'm sure it's
on the tip of all of your tongues as it
is for most of us the ninth amendment
says the enumeration in the constitution
of certain rights shall not be construed
to deny or disparage other rights
retained by the people now when you
think about it that's exactly the
language you would use to say that there
are unenumerated rights right you'd say
yes they're enumerated rights but that's
not a complete list how else could you
say that better you could use fewer
commas than Madison used but their
punctuation was a little bit odd in
those days and if you read carefully
what Madison said in introducing the 9th
amendment
he really nailed down the fact that
that's what he's trying to do so
Madison's solution was add the 9th
amendment make it clear that there are
unenumerated rights in the period after
1800 this idea of unenumerated rights of
unwritten legal rules that were in the
background remained powerful the
anti-slavery movement in particular
relied heavily on this idea to explain
why slavery was unacceptable because
inconsistent with what they called the
law of nations the law that governed
humanity generally and governed
relationships between nations we don't
have anything that we with quite that
same scope in current law combine bits
and pieces if you were looking for law
school courses you would find there's a
little bit of it here there's some of
the international law course there's
some in the constitutional law course
but we don't categorize those things as
all being United the way they did then
and this side people who were arguing
this about slavery were the same ones
who wrote the 4th 15th amendment which
among other things applied the Bill of
Rights to the states but they also made
it clear that they didn't think rights
were created by some enumeration rights
exist prior to an enumeration and the
Constitution merely acknowledges those
rights so I think if you read the
Constitution carefully and just take a
look at what the language is saying or
if you go and look at the language of
the of Madison and others during the
period it seems to me that the message
of the 9th amendment is pretty
unmistakable I don't think that's always
true one of the problems with
originalism is the assumption that
history always has a clear answer for
modern-day constitutional issues I think
that's often wrong but in this
particular case I think it's right now
if you're interested people have come up
with various clever lawyerly arguments
to avoid what I think is the pretty
plain historical record but I'm not
going to go into trying to deal with all
of those right now
so now you might be asking well that's
all very well so there are these
unenumerated rights but since they're
unenumerated how do we decide what
rights are protected and I don't think
that there's a magical formula for doing
that that is I can't say well there's
this like computer program algorithm
five-part recipe that will infallibly
tell you if something is or is not an
unenumerated right but I think on the
other hand that it's not just an
arbitrary choice that there are pretty
clear guidelines that can often be
helpful in resolving that question and
the case that I like to use as an
example where I think the court used
basically the right kind of analysis is
the Lawrence case this was the case
where a majority of the Supreme Court
ruled that Texas law making it a crime
to engage in homosexual conduct
homosexual sodomy as the statute said
the court declared that statute
unconstitutional and overruled a prior
case in doing so now what did this did
the court should say oh no we believe in
gay rights and therefore we're going to
rule this way no in fact the court
looked at a fair amount of evidence that
showed that the previous decision was
just out of tune with contemporary
society and contemporary views of human
rights one of the indications of that
was at a number of state courts and
interpreting their own local
constitutions had refused to follow that
decision so for example now I'm not just
talking about the like left coast but
for example the Kentucky Supreme Court
had refused to follow that decision
second most state legislatures had
rejected these laws where the laws had
previously been on the books many of
them were repealed and even in states
that had these laws they were very
rarely enforced so Texas was and a few
other states were really pushing against
the current here and then finally and
the thing that I think drove Justice
Scalia and other critics of the court
the craziest was that the court referred
to decisions by the European Court of
Human Rights about
similar issues to show that there was in
fact a kind of emerging international
consensus that individual autonomy and
privacy includes the right to engage in
sexual conduct with partners of your
choice that that laws prohibiting
conduct by homosexuals just couldn't be
sustained in the modern world now this
was a huge issue and I think if you
believe that the as some people like
Scalia do that the Constitution is this
peculiar homegrown thing we created
these specially American rights that we
made well then it's kind of natural to
think maybe we can't learn anything from
anyone else because they've got their
own way of doing things they've got
their own rights that they've created
but if you don't view rights that way if
you think that rights are there in the
first place and that we and the
Europeans and the Supreme Court of
Israel and the Supreme Court of
Australia or New Zealand that we're all
looking at similar kinds of things the
international rights conventions all of
these things that we're all sort of
struggling to identify basic human
rights then it makes a lot of sense to
look around the world and see what other
people are doing so there was this huge
firestorm of protest there were calls in
the House of Representatives to impeach
the justices for the sin of referring to
non American legal authority and again
if you go back and look at the history
this is completely nuts in terms of the
framers who are constantly referring to
foreign legal sources and if you look at
the early US Supreme Court same thing
you find Chief Justice Marshall and
these other great early justices
referring over and over again to
European decisions to European legal
authors to Roman law to all kinds of
things that were not made in America
originally and that's because of this
idea that the law doesn't create these
rights and the law doesn't create basic
ideas about democracy it only recognizes
those those ideas well I think
that's enough to give you at least the
flavor of the book I'm kind of
programmed to talk in 50-minute units
because that's how long our classes are
but I don't want to impose on your
patience so and besides I'm really much
more interested in having a discussion
and seeing what kinds of questions and
ideas you might have about this so so
I'd like to just open it up for
questions at this point rights and and
said well this is a case where there is
an unenumerated right yes the Supreme
Court has often on referred to
unenumerated rights but through a kind
of historical accident instead of using
the Ninth Amendment
they've shoehorned this idea into the
due process clause and that has left the
court very vulnerable because it really
doesn't fit with the due process clause
and so it's very easy for critics to
just knock holes in that and say it's
just made-up law and and doesn't have
any legitimacy so part of what I'm
trying to do with this book is actually
to take some decisions that the court
has made you should under the rubric of
due process but that have been really
trashed by critics like Scalia and to
show how they can have a much firmer
foundation the 9th amendment itself
though has only rarely gotten a side
look from the Supreme Court and I think
that's largely a matter of historical
accident more than anything else just
just the way the timing worked out and
the way legal thought at various
different times was heading
in any other constitutions well that's a
very interesting question the state
constitutions after the 9th amendment
almost always include a similar language
so at least it was something that was
popular in the United States other
constitutions tend not to have that I
know about and I'm not an expert on
international constitutional law other
constitutions tend not to have something
that's phrase the same way so instead of
saying for example that there are
unenumerated rights the they will say
something like there's a basic right to
human dignity and which is in the german
constitution and then because that
wretch human dignity is obviously cause
for a lot of interpretation then what we
might do under the guise of unenumerated
rights they might be able to do under
the guise of protecting basic dignity so
I think other legal systems tend to have
other ways of doing things but that
often come out in the same way so so I
think that the specifics of the ninth
amendment are maybe partly result of our
own history of the fact that our
Constitution was written in an earlier
period but I think this basic impulse to
connect constitutional law with a
broader vision of human rights
that's not limited to a single time or
place I think that that's very
widespread very good question
Supreme Court is a just a constitutional
law explanatory term in the the Supreme
Court has really used it once in the
Griswold case there was a 1963 case the
question was whether the state of
Connecticut could ban the use of birth
control and the majority opinion by
Justice Douglas said well it's not
exactly in the First Amendment and it's
not exactly in the Fourth Amendment
which protects privacy by requiring
search warrants and it's not exactly
part of freedom of association but it's
in the penumbra of all of those
meaningless shadow right and I think
that's kind of a nice image but it's an
image that was immediately mocked by
almost all lawyers and legal observers
as being you know sort of completely
unbasic institutions and really just an
exist Asst Douglas was kind of famous
for his willingness to sort of skip over
legal niceties and that's one way of
putting it or making up the laws way
other people put it and so this was kind
of seen as an example of Justice
Douglass's personal foibles it's
interesting one of the separate opinions
in the case does refer to the ninth
amendment and that's the major time that
the ninth amendment has come up in the
Supreme Court and then there's an uh
there are other important issue opinions
on this issue by Justice Harlan who was
the most conservative member of the
Warren Court but who believed via due
process that the Constitution protects
forms of Liberty beyond those that are
specifically listed so different judges
have kind of groped after this concept
of unenumerated rights using different
metaphors and different ideas and part
of what I'm trying to do is show how you
can really do it in a pretty
straightforward way
in the the little write-up here about
your talk you mentioned that well it
says that yet this amendment has never
been the basis for a Supreme Court
decision do you think that I'm an
engineer not a lawyer but born and
raised in the United States I have some
familiarity with our common culture do
you think that this this the ninth
amendment might be usefully made use of
by someone arguing a case or or is it
it's not the purview of someone to in
arguing that case to suggest which
amendment to use it's the purview of the
justices to to choose which amendment to
choose to address the issue brought
before the court well for a lawyer of
course the path of least resistance is
always trying to you know figure out
where the judges are heading and then
turn it to your advantage so if the
judges prefer to speak in terms of due
process as a lawyer your tendency is
simply to go along and that I think
that's one reason why the issue hasn't
really resurfaced because it's just
easier to head down that same path the
problem is that once that idea of due
process and and using it once that's
challenged by people like Scalia it's
very weak and so it seems to me a kind
of natural way to bring in the ninth
amendment would be to say you know that
that's people you know some people have
raised questions about the use of the
due process clause to protect privacy
but that's bolstered by the ninth
amendment is shown by you know the
brilliant recent work of etc so I think
there are ways for lawyers to kind of
work it in and build begin to build more
judicial acceptance but it takes time
the court well you know it's both good
and bad that the court doesn't usually
turn on
and one you know and therefore once they
become attached to a certain way of
doing things they tend to stick with it
I think that that can be a very good
force for stability in the law but
sometimes it makes a little harder to
get them to address new ideas but I
think that the views of Justice Scalia
in particular really kind of beg for
that kind of response I can follow up
what might you suggest what type of
issue relevant in our society today or
in the near future 5 10 15 years might
be an issue where and a line of
reasoning or a line of arguing based on
what you've just said might be
productively used and applying this in
this type of case right what type of
case would would be a or what type of
issue would be a good one to use with
making this this type of progress right
well I think it could be brought to some
extent to bear on almost all of the
cases where the court talks about
privacy or other issues but I think it
might be most useful perhaps in trying
to get the court to reconsider some of
its existing doctrines such as the
deshaney case the one with the little
boy who was beaten another area that I
suggest calls for a reconsideration is
whether the Constitution protects the
right to an adequate education not an
excellent education but at least a one
that prepares a person for the minimum
demands of society the court has danced
around that issue but basically given
the signal know that they're not going
to get involved and I think the 9th
amendment would be kind of a natural fit
in terms of that argument so I think
there are not one of the things I try to
do in the book is look at some areas
that the court has talked about but then
also try to reach into some other areas
that the court had where the court
hasn't protected rights to try to show
how the Ninth Amendment
be used and I should say the ninth
amendment has a one of the sort of
technicalities is that the ninth
amendment really applies to the federal
government but there's a similar clause
called the privileges or immunities
clause in the Fourteenth Amendment that
applies to the states and again I think
that that Clause could be very
powerfully used in particular on issues
like education and in fact there's some
specific legislative history from that
period showing the members of Congress
connected the idea of privileges and
immunities of citizenship with the idea
of a right to an education one of my
colleagues Goodwin Liu has done a lot of
work on that issue down the road can be
used to protect a woman's right to have
her doctor make a medical decision where
to terminate the fetus either in her
body or out of her body visa vie the
latest tragic decision that's come down
throughout that could the ninth
amendment and do you think it might be
used to counteract that case well I
think that what the 9th amendment is
most useful for I think is to counteract
the idea that this issue is not in the
courts business the idea that people
like Scalia and Justice Thomas have
promoted that Constitution just doesn't
say anything one way or the other so you
could have laws that prohibit abortions
you could have laws that mandate
abortions just none of our businesses
judges I think that the III I think that
the 9th amendment pretty clearly speaks
against that now abortion I think is
just a hard issue and what makes it hard
is not the question of whether there is
a fundamental right involved I don't I
really don't think that that's a hard
question but the question is how to
balance that against what so many people
feel is a powerful interest on the other
side and I you know I have sympathy with
judges and trying to strike that balance
but I think that judges at least have a
responsibility to make sure that
legislators strike a responsible
balanced that they give credence to the
one
right even if they decide under some
circumstances to limited and I think
that many state legislators today maybe
don't need a court to tell them that but
some of them apparently do and so I
think that the ninth amendment could
play an important role there but I don't
want to claim that if you just look at
the ninth amendment all the hard
questions of American constitutional law
just go you know become easy and simple
that's not I think some of them become
simple but some of them some of them are
really just hard questions and what the
9th amendment does is get rid of some
distracting arguments and maybe help the
court focus on what the really hard
issue is like how to strike that balance
of these unenumerated rights and how do
you envision they could be most
effectively used against us good ok yes
I you know I think it's the dangers to
be honest I think Justice Scalia is
actually capable of understanding the
language of the ninth amendment and for
that matter I suspect judge Bork was as
well what I think is motivating them is
this fear that really they're you know
you're opening a door you have no idea
where it might go there are no limits on
what the court might do it would all be
just political and so one of the things
I try to do is to show that there are
guideposts at least that the court can
look to to not necessarily give all the
answers but at least to to rule out some
answers and to help focus the inquiry in
terms of the dangers I think the example
that everybody in the con law field uses
is case called Lochner which was almost
exactly 100 years ago and in that case
the Supreme Court said that that a state
could not regulate the maximum hours of
workers because that violated the
workers god-given Liberty of contract
right so that that's sort of the Bugaboo
that that we I know I maybe I shouldn't
quite use that term because I think that
there's a really legitimate concern
there that in retrospect now it just
looks like these very conservative
judges we're imposing their own views of
economic regulation claiming that this
was somehow inherent in the Constitution
I don't think there's any way we can
completely eliminate that possibility
because at the end of the day to some
extent we have to rely on picking good
judges and on their willingness to try
to control themselves to try to be
intellectually honest to try to follow
look for legal guideposts not simply
decide on right answers and and head off
that way I eat a lot of people think
well if we could just get the right
formula we can keep the judges from
doing bad things and that's like the
then so that's the basis of Justice
Scalia's philosophy I hate to keep
banging on Scalia but at the same time I
could just can't resist so his theory is
if we just all use originalism then this
will just be an inquiry into history and
the judges politics won't enter into
anything and it'll all be very objective
and we won't have to worry about judges
running amuck and I just don't think
that's right I just don't think there's
any way that you can tie judges up in
words so that bad judges who are just
you know unrestrained and uninterested
in anything except their own political
agenda you can't stop them by throwing
history books at them or by throwing
precedents at them because a judge who
wants to confined a way out
at some level we have you know we have
to pay attention to who's going on the
court and we have to do as much as we
can to ensure that those people are
going to be responsible that they're
gonna have balanced judgment that
they're not just going to be knee-jerk
ideologues realistically can we expect
100 percent success no I think that it's
almost certain that if judges are
deciding these issues sometimes they
will make a mistake in the direction of
protecting something they shouldn't be
protecting so it's really a question of
trade-offs we could
stop that if we could get the judges not
to protect any rights at all but I think
that's too high price to pay I think
that we have to be willing now and then
to to it admit the possibility that they
might go a little too far because it's
critically important that they go far
enough so I think that that's a chance
that we should should take and I think
for example if you look at the Lochner
decision specifically and you look at
the kinds of guideposts that I've been
talking about in fact if they had
followed this approach they wouldn't
have issued this decision I mean they
just would not have found the kind of
support for example in the international
community for this freedom from maximum
wage laws they I don't think they would
have found the other kinds of support
that I'm calling for so I think that at
least ideally you could have this
approach without having that kind of
excess but you know like you know we're
talking about a human activity here
people will make mistakes and we just
what we have to decide is what kinds of
mistakes are we willing to risk I think
the mistake of having the Supreme Court
validate violations of human rights I
think that's a worse mistake than the
occasional decision that provides some
protection that the court ideally
shouldn't do but that's a question of
whether like the framers and others
whether we take this idea of human
rights seriously whether we think it's a
really really bad thing for the
government to be violating human rights
or is it just kind of a small cost to
pay every once in a while we send a
grandmother to jail but we don't do it
very often it's not that big a deal or
do we want to say even you know sending
even one grandmother to jail locking up
even one gay couple for their activities
that's too much
how the this ninth amendment would
compare to something quite powerful like
the Civil Rights Amendment in this
respect the I worked on a documentary
film where I was doing research on a
person a prisoner we've been in prison
for a long time he had decided he was
gonna fake that he was crazy thinking
this would he'd get an easier task and
he wanted for the electric shock and all
but what he told me was when the civil
rights movement passed which sometimes
we think of as something to give rights
to African Americans the whole thing in
prison changed absolutely complete turn
over because he now had rights that he
didn't have before now that seems pretty
powerful in comparison to say the ninth
amendment which as you've said hasn't
really been used that much what about
this added these the ability to add
something as powerful as that to the
Constitution well I don't think the 9th
amendment is the only thing in the
Constitution that's important and so I
think anti-discrimination rules are also
very important and not covered by the
9th amendment itself but I think I would
also say that well I mean what what
happened in 1960s was that going beyond
the Constitution itself Congress enacted
legislation to enforce the
constitutional rights to be free from
discrimination so they passed the 1964
Civil Rights Act in the 1965 Voting
Rights Act in particular one of the
things that the 9th amendment could be
used for I've been talking in terms of
the court but the 9th amendment also
could provide a platform for Congress
the Ninth Amendment and the Fourteenth
Amendment counterpart that could
authorize broader congressional
legislation protecting various forms of
Rights so even if even if you think that
this is too open-ended or dangerous to
be entrusted to judges it might still
have uses in terms of allowing Congress
to pass legislation dealing with some of
these
issues of like a woman's right to choose
or termination of medical treatment
that's been another issue where privacy
has been volved do you have the right to
tell them you know you're dying turn off
the respirator maybe Congress should be
able to legislate something about that
and they might be able to use these
ideas as a basis for legislation so I
think these things can all work together
I don't think it's either/or in the back
the framers think of rights that are
reserved to corporations
since corporations weren't an 18th
century concept and yet today we think
of corporations as having parity of
rights with individuals what reserved
rights are there for corporations most
of the kinds of rights that I'm
interested in really just couldn't apply
to a corporation right corporations
don't need contraceptives or protection
against being physically abused or a
right to go to get an adequate education
so to some extent I think that's a
question I can dodge my view would be
and this is really outside of the book
that we should recognize rights and
corporations only when doing so protects
the rights of individuals right so if we
say corporations never have any rights
the problem with that is that a lot of
times people can only do things through
corporations the new york times is a
corporation right we don't we want to
say that that the New York Times has
constitutional rights it's not because
some corporation does it's really
because the editors and journalists who
work there and the individual who
publishes it I have rights now I think a
number of the Supreme Court's decisions
about corporations rights make sense
when you think of them that way but not
all of them not all of the decisions so
I think in some areas the Supreme Court
has been kind of led astray by the idea
that the rights belong to the
corporation itself rather than to actual
human beings
yeah I'm coming in late so you might
have already addressed this and I
apologize if you did
are there any landmark cases more recent
that have used the ninth amendment as a
basis for protecting a very P right that
you see needed to be protected and is
their way of you know gaining media
attention to that so that people I
basically haven't even heard about the
Ninth Amendment particularly so I'm
wondering if that can be used to build
more awareness that we actually are
protected in other ways besides you know
our other constitutional rights that we
seem to more generally know about right
now the answer is no the the the courts
have really shied away since about the
time of roe v wade the abortion decision
in the period of time between the
contraception decision that i mentioned
before the sort of 10 years between then
and the abortion decision a number of
lower courts look to places like the 9th
amendment for support but when the
abortion issue got back to the Supreme
Court the court for reasons known only
to itself decided to rely on the due
process clause and we don't really know
why because the opinion doesn't try to
explain it it just says well it could be
here it could be there we think it's due
process period so we don't have a lot of
that recent thing so I think we need to
build in that direction I think in
briefs to the court lawyers need to
start making those arguments and help it
to show the judges who were sympathetic
to the idea of unenumerated rights that
that they could find a much more solid
foundation than the one they're trying
to use now and that they don't have to
put up with being criticized as for
ignoring original intent and
constitutional attacks that in fact
they've got very powerful counter
arguments against their critics so
unfortunately there's no equivalent of
the nra which has taken the Second
Amendment from complete obscurity and
you know made it somebody's in a poll it
was the only constitutional amendment
most people could could name so there's
no national unenumerated rights
Association that's going to engage in
that crew say
on behalf of the ninth amendment that
could be AB well where else but Berkeley
well thanks I really appreciate everyone
coming out here tonight and engaging in
such a stimulating discussion so thank
you
[Applause]